Hey everybody, welcome to another exciting interview. Today, we have Andrew Yates from Promoted AI, co-founder and CEO there. So welcome to the show, Andrew. Hi, thanks for having me. So we have a lot of interesting things. We were doing our, I guess, our pre-shows inside baseball. We talked to Andrew for a few minutes before we start. And, you know, I think there's a number of topics we've never really talked about before. So I'm excited to dig in. But first, we always ask people, how did you kind of get into programming? What is like your first programming experience? We can start there.
大家好，欢迎收看另一期精彩的访谈。今天，我们请到了 Promoted AI 的联合创始人兼首席执行官 Andrew Yates。欢迎来到节目，Andrew。嗨，谢谢邀请我。所以我们有很多有趣的事情。我们在开始前，大概算是做了一些开场前的内部交流。我们在开始前和 Andrew 聊了几分钟。而且，你知道，我认为有很多我们以前从未真正讨论过的话题。所以我很高兴能深入探讨。但首先，我们总是问大家，你是怎么走上编程这条路的？你的第一次编程经历是什么样的？我们可以从这里开始。
Oh, yeah. Oh, that's a great question. When I was in high school, there was a program where Apple computer provided a bunch of free laptops for students and i just loved it and i remember it was like this silly true basic little developer environment and and i remember i was like wow i can make my own games and like yeah so i made like all of these rocket game and i remember coding the theme for zelda using like you have to use like the actual integers for the tones so it was like trying to figure out the spacing of it. And I don't know, I just really got into it and then it was getting into web design. So this was for me, it was back in high school and I just, the joy of, oh my gosh, I could control this computer. And I ended up buying
哦，是的。哦，这真是个好问题。当我在高中时，有一个项目是苹果电脑为学生提供了一批免费笔记本电脑，我简直太喜欢了，我记得那就像是一个很傻的 True BASIC 小开发环境，而且我记得当时我想，哇，我可以制作自己的游戏了，所以我就做了所有这些火箭游戏，我记得我还用类似必须使用音调的实际整数的方式编写了塞尔达传说的主题曲，所以这就像是在摸索它的间距。而且我不知道，我真的迷上了它，然后开始接触网页设计。所以对我来说，这回到了高中时期，我那种“天哪，我可以控制这台计算机”的喜悦感，最终我买下了
my own computer. Yeah. Actually for me, I, geez, I remember I worked at McDonald's for like $5 an hour and saved up for like $1,500 on my own computer. So I could do, you know, I guess I played some games on it too, but it was the joy of just being able to not only build things and see it work, but also for me, I love the entrepreneurial aspect of it. I started my own web design agency, you know, when I was in high school and that kind of stuff, I love the entrepreneurial aspect of it. I started my own web design agency, you know, when I was in high school, and that kind of stuff. I ended up skipping school and joined an e commerce company. I live in the Midwest. It wasn't a very successful e commerce company. But like, I'm sorry if we processed your credit card, because I wrote that code, you know, like,
我自己的电脑。是的。其实对我来说，天哪，我记得我在麦当劳打工，大概每小时 5 美元，然后自己存了大约 1,500 美元买了我自己的电脑。这样我就可以，你知道，我猜我也在上面玩了一些游戏，但那种不仅能够构建东西并看着它运行的喜悦感，对我来说，我也喜欢它的创业方面。我还在上高中时就创立了自己的网页设计公司，诸如此类的事情，我喜欢它的创业方面。我还在上高中时就创立了自己的网页设计公司，诸如此类的事情。我最后甚至逃课去了一家电子商务公司上班。我住在中西部。那并不是一家非常成功的电子商务公司。但是，如果有人处理过你的信用卡，我很抱歉，因为那段代码是我写的，你知道的，就像是，
it was awesome. Like I actually did like take my test at school and then like kind of skip out. And it was an interesting time. But anyways, that's how I got started. Oh, very good. So do you still have all those old programs? Or are they lost to the bit? Oh, absolutely not. No, of course not. And they're not good either. It was just I don't know, the joy of seeing writing something and then watching it run was pretty exciting. Yeah, I came across an old game I wrote in college for a class and played it for a few minutes. And it's like, wow, this is really bad. That was before a lot of the I'll date myself a bit, I guess I was before a lot of the sort of frameworks and stuff that make writing games a little bit easier today. So that'll be my excuse. So then did you end up going
这太棒了。我实际上是在学校考完试然后就溜出去了。那是一段有趣的时光。不过无论如何，这就是我开始的方式。哦，非常棒。那你还留着所有那些旧程序吗？还是说它们已经随着数据化时代消失了？哦，绝对没有。不，当然没有。而且它们也不好。那只是，我不知道，看到自己写出一些东西然后看着它运行的那种喜悦感是相当令人兴奋的。是的，我偶然发现了我在大学里为一门课写的一个旧游戏，然后玩了几分钟。这就好像，哇，这真的很糟糕。那是在很多，我也算是暴露年龄了，我猜那是很多让编写游戏变得稍微容易一点的框架和东西出现之前的事。所以这就是我的借口。那么你最后有没有去
to college for programming? Or did you end up going straight into kind of working? Oh, no, I went to school for computer science. And then I ultimately did master's and I did a PhD and I was going to do bioinformatics. I wanted to work on curing cancer. And I was really interested in genomics. And I thought like, oh, the cell would be the next engineering platform or some ridiculous kind of idea, which is sounds cool. But no, that's not the case. And I ended up switching out of cancer research and joined the technology industry and came out here to San Francisco. Nice. Yeah. So speaking of I've been this recent hobby now with you can get print
大学学习编程？还是说你最后直接去工作了？哦，不，我学的是计算机科学。然后我最终读了硕士，还读了博士，我本来打算做生物信息学。我想致力于治愈癌症。我对基因组学真的很感兴趣。我当时想，哦，细胞将成为下一个工程平台，或者类似的一些荒谬的想法，听起来很酷。但事实并非如此。我最终退出了癌症研究，加入了科技行业，然后来到了旧金山。太棒了。是的。所以说到这个，我最近有一个新爱好，就是你可以买到
on demand plasmids. And so actually, like that whole I was I remember that phase where all the DNA computer or whatever. But now you actually can sort of like from your garage basically like inject custom dna information into cells and stuff it's a fascinating rabbit hole yeah it's getting that that should be the next guest you should have is someone on in that space but 10 years ago or so it wasn't anything like that it was like oh you can do your own pcr tests which we did do uh that that's like you're watching little paper blotter. It didn't really blow people's mind. Yeah, that's true. Running the gel. Yeah. I mean, now PCR people associate with something completely different than they did 10 years ago. So now PCR tests are all about COVID. Yeah. Yeah. So very good. So how did you end up at Promoted AI and
按需打印的质粒。所以实际上，就像整个，我记得那个所有 DNA 计算机之类的阶段。但现在你实际上可以从你的车库里，基本上就像是把定制的 DNA 信息注入细胞等等，这是一个迷人的知识深洞。是的，这应该成为你的下一个嘉宾，你应该请一个该领域的人来。但大约 10 年前，根本不是这样的，当时是“哦，你可以自己做 PCR 测试”，我们确实做了，那就像你在看一张纸质印迹。这并没有真正让人脑洞大开。是的，是真的。跑胶。是的。我的意思是，现在人们对 PCR 的联想与 10 年前完全不同了。所以现在 PCR 测试全都是关于新冠病毒的。是的。是的。非常好。那你最后是怎么加入 Promoted AI 并
getting that off the ground? Yeah. So a little bit about leaving PhD program, I figured, well, hey, if I'm not going to be curing cancer, do the industry of the area, which is ads. So learn about that. Joined Facebook and I did. So I worked at Facebook ads back in optimization and then later Twitter and then Pinterest. But before I went into that, I was always, like I mentioned, I just started up dreams. I had always wanted to start my own company. The idea was I would go work in industry for some time, learn the ropes, learn the industry, get some deep insider knowledge about how it works, and then start my own company. And promoted AI is that.
将其创立起来的呢？是的。所以关于离开博士项目，我想，好吧，嘿，如果我不去治愈癌症的话，那就去做这个领域的产业，也就是广告。所以去了解那个领域。加入了 Facebook，我做到了。我在 Facebook 广告部门从事优化工作，后来去了 Twitter，然后是 Pinterest。但在我进入这些公司之前，我一直都像我提到的那样，我刚开始创业时就有了梦想。我一直想创办自己的公司。我的想法是先在行业里工作一段时间，摸清门道，了解这个行业，获得关于它是如何运作的深刻内部知识，然后创办我自己的公司。而 Promoted AI 就是这样。
So I think just recently, there was a Y Combinator video about doing big tech, but you need to have a plan about when you're going to leave to do your startup. Otherwise, you'll never leave. And I did that. Oh, very good. Yeah, I think that I mean, I guess being in that area, that's true. People talk about it as golden handcuffs. It's not exactly what golden handcuffs mean, I think. But for people who don't know, once you start working at those big tech companies, often it comes with stock grants that vest over a certain number of years. And then if the company stock grows, all of a sudden not having a plan means you're faced with leaving a very lucrative job in order to sort of go to kind of do your own. This is a bit of a tangent, but look, that is a fantastic problem to have.
所以我想就在最近，有一个关于搞大厂的 Y Combinator 视频，但是你需要有一个关于你什么时候离开去创业的计划。否则你永远都不会离开。而我做到了。哦，非常好。是的，我认为，我的意思是，在这个领域里确实如此。人们把它称为“金手铐”。这其实并不完全是“金手铐”的本意，我认为。但对于那些不知道的人来说，一旦你开始在那些大型科技公司工作，通常会伴随着在若干年内归属的股票期权。然后如果公司的股票上涨，突然之间，如果没有计划，就意味着你面临着放弃一份非常丰厚的工作去开始做你自己的事情。这有点离题了，但是听着，这是一个非常棒的问题。
Oh no, look at all of the money that I'm making. Like really? And look, oh, I have this fantastic resume. I think the challenge though is if your goal is to start your own company or you have ambitions to do more than simply have a fantastic career, then you eventually have to not be doing that.
哦，不，看看我赚了多少钱。真的吗？你看，哦，我有一份这么棒的简历。不过我认为挑战在于，如果你的目标是创办自己的公司，或者你有远大的志向，不仅仅是拥有一份棒极了的职业生涯，那么你最终必须不再做那些事。
It's a good problem to have of, oh no, I have this fantastic career at a company that I like. I guess if you hate your job, that's another issue. But I just want to call out that the golden handcuffs, you can leave, you can quit, but you stay because it pays well and the work isn't typically that
这是一个很好的问题，比如“哦，不，我在一家我喜欢的公司拥有如此棒的职业生涯”。我想如果你讨厌你的工作，那是另一回事。但我只是想指出，“金手铐”，你可以离开，你可以辞职，但你留下来是因为它薪水很高，而且工作通常也不是那么
challenging, although it can be frustrating if you are really passionate about building your own system or doing it in a much better way. And in fact, that's the motivation for Promoted AI and our recruitment pitch for the people that we've hired is, look, you've been there, done that for big tech. If someone's going to pay you X, it's worth a lot more to them. Y is greater than X. They have to be worth more to whoever's paying you. However much you're getting paid, someone's paying you that amount, right? And you've kind of been there, done that, and you know the way the sausage is being made at some of these tech companies is pretty sloppy, really sloppy, and you're tired of it. And this is especially for the type of marketplace optimization work that we
具有挑战性，尽管如果你真的热衷于构建自己的系统或者用好得多方式去做，它可能会令人沮丧。事实上，这就是 Promoted AI 的动机，也是我们对所招聘人员的招聘话术：看，大厂的那些事你都经历过了，也做过了。如果有人要付给你 X，那对他们来说价值要高得多。Y 大于 X。无论谁在付给你钱，你对他们来说都必须更有价值。无论你拿多少薪水，总有人在付给你这个数，对吧？你算是在那里经历过、做过了，而且你知道其中一些科技公司香肠是怎么做出来的相当马虎，真的很马虎，而且你已经厌倦了。这尤其是对于我们所做的这种市场优化工作而言，
do, where I do believe that Facebook and Google do a fantastic job. This is their core business, and this is what they're really good at. But if you go down the list of every other company, I mean, even Pinterest, but different marketplaces like DoorDash or Airbnb, and then you go down the list of every other company, I mean, even Pinterest, but different marketplaces like DoorDash or Airbnb, and then you go down the list of all the different marketplaces or e-commerce companies in the world. No, they're not really doing a fantastic job of matching buyers and sellers and solving this. And if you're really passionate about doing that fantastically well, you're not going to be able to accomplish that by just going to work at another company. So you need to do it for yourselves, own it for yourselves. And then our plan is, well, do it really well, like fantastically well, without all of the pressures of internal politics
我确实相信 Facebook 和 Google 做得非常出色。这是他们的核心业务，也是他们真正擅长的领域。但如果你顺着其他每家公司的名单看下去，我的意思是，甚至 Pinterest，但像 DoorDash 或 Airbnb 这样的不同市场，然后你顺着其他每家公司的名单看下去，我的意思是，甚至 Pinterest，但像 DoorDash 或 Airbnb 这样的不同市场，然后你顺着世界上所有不同市场或电子商务公司的名单看下去。不，他们在匹配买家和卖家以及解决这个问题方面并没有真正做得非常出色。如果你真的热衷于把这件事做得非常出色，你仅仅靠去另一家公司工作是无法实现这一目标的。所以你需要为自己去做，为自己拥有它。然后我们的计划是，好吧，把它做好，做到极致，抛开内部政治的所有压力，
and the quarterly stuff and product managers have to get something out the door, but then it's a mess and it never gets fixed. Let's do it right. And then you have it, you own it, and you can provide it as a service to all of these companies and really help them grow. So, I mean, that was a great segue into sort of talking about, I think the show's topic, which is let's start by saying, what is a marketplace? I mean, maybe people understand it as, oh, I go down to the bazaar down the street and there's merchant selling stuff. But when you say marketplace, what do you mean? Yeah, I mean in a really abstract way, which is you have buyers and you have sellers or you have consumers and you have producers and you're trying to match these two groups.
还有季度性的东西，产品经理们不得不把产品推向市场，但随后它一团糟，而且永远得不到解决。让我们把它做好。然后你拥有它，你可以把它作为一项服务提供给所有这些公司，并真正帮助他们成长。所以，我的意思是，这是一个很好的过渡，可以谈谈，我认为本节目的主题，也就是让我们从说“什么是市场”开始。我的意思是，也许人们理解它是，哦，我走到街上的集市，那里有商人在卖东西。但当你提到市场时，你指的是什么？是的，我的意思是，从一个非常抽象的角度来看，也就是你有买家，你有卖家，或者你有消费者，你有生产者，而你正试图将这两组人匹配起来。
And one example of this is Airbnb or HipCamp, where you have people who are looking for a vacation place and you have people who are posting listings and you need to match these two. Another example is social media. You have people who are posting whatever it is that their stories, their news, and then you have people who are consuming that news. And the challenge is for the marketplace and like an online marketplace is how do you match the consumers with the producers and also be able to make money from that? And these three groups all have similar objectives, but they're quite different. So for example, you probably never, ever want to see an ad, but nevertheless, Facebook or Reddit, they're going to show you ads. Well, okay. Our sellers want to make as much money as possible, but there are other sellers.
其中一个例子是 Airbnb 或 HipCamp，在那里你有寻找度假场所的人，也有发布房源的人，你需要将这两者匹配起来。另一个例子是社交媒体。你有发布他们故事、他们新闻的人，然后你有消费这些新闻的人。而对于市场以及像在线市场这样的挑战是，你如何将消费者与生产者匹配起来，并且还能从中赚钱？这三组人都有相似的目标，但它们相当不同。例如，你可能永远、永远不想看到广告，但尽管如此，Facebook 或 Reddit 还是会向你展示广告。好吧，没关系。我们的卖家希望赚尽可能多的钱，但还有其他卖家。
So why have a diversity? They want to always be first in search, for example, but that's not fair to other sellers and it may not be the best thing for buyers because maybe there's a cheaper price or there's a better match out there. So this idea of solving marketplace is you have these three different parties and how do you present the right offers, the right search results, the right feed results, the right recommendations so that it's balanced, so that all three parties are maximized in some way. So there's a lot to unpack there. If we kind of go back to where you were starting off,
那么为什么要有多样性？例如，他们总是希望在搜索中名列前茅，但这对于其他卖家来说并不公平，而且对买家来说可能也不是最好的事情，因为可能存在更便宜的价格，或者外面有更好的匹配。所以解决市场的这个想法是，你有这三个不同的方，你如何呈现正确的报价、正确的搜索结果、正确的信息流结果、正确的推荐，以便它是平衡的，以便所有三方都在某种程度上最大化。所以这里有很多需要剖析的地方。如果我们回到你开始的地方，
do you think in a marketplace that there's a difference between, you mentioned like social media, do you think there's a fundamental difference between, hey, I'm posting a comment, you're coming along, and you want to see that comment where there isn't, let's call it explicit financial, you know, transaction taking place? I'm just writing on Twitter, hey, here's what I had for lunch today. And you know, Twitter might want to show you that because you think that's interesting. Is there a fundamental difference between that and I'm an advertiser saying, look, lunch, we're serving at a restaurant today, and I'm willing to pay you to see that. Do you think that is all sort of part of one in the same, or is there a fundamental difference there? Ooh, great question. I think of it as fundamentally the same, which is it's an attention marketplace. So that's a great point here, which is if you
你认为在一个市场中，两者之间有什么区别，你提到了社交媒体，你认为在“嘿，我发表了一条评论，你过来了，你想看那条评论”之间存在根本区别吗？那里并没有，我们称之为显式的财务交易发生。我只是在 Twitter 上写着，嘿，这是我今天的午餐。你知道，Twitter 可能想向你展示这一点，因为你认为这很有趣。你认为这与“我是一个广告商，说，看，我们今天在餐馆供应午餐，我愿意付钱让你看到这个”之间存在根本区别吗？你认为这基本上是同一回事的一部分，还是说其中存在根本区别？噢，好问题。我认为这基本上是一样的，也就是它是一个注意力市场。所以这里有一个很好的观点，也就是如果你
really zoom out here, all you're looking at is your phone screen. That's it. It's just your phone screen. And then just text and images on your phone screen. Even in a commercial sense, if I'm looking on Amazon, it's still text and images on your phone screen. And yes, you can start layering on pieces like, okay, there's a commercial interest. And by the way, promoted AI focuses on commercial attention marketplace. But when you zoom out from this and you think, all right, all I have are texts and images and placements on a screen. And then how am I going to solve this attention matching marketplace where there's no longer
真正把视野拉远，你所看的全部东西就是你的手机屏幕。就是这样。它只是你的手机屏幕。然后就是你手机屏幕上的文字和图像。即使在商业意义上，如果我在亚马逊上搜索，它依然是你手机屏幕上的文字和图像。是的，你可以开始叠加一些部分，比如，好吧，这里有商业利益。顺便说一句，Promoted AI 专注于商业注意力市场。但当你从这个角度拉远视野，并思考，好的，我所有的只是屏幕上的文字、图像和位置。然后我将如何解决这个注意力匹配市场，而这里不再有
this concept of for commerce and retail? There's not a store. There's not a store. There's not like a physical location. It's just people's attention that you're trying to capture in certain ways. And the only tools you have to do that are audio, visual, movies, and images, and text, and different channels for being able to send that information. That's all you have. So for the purpose of sending social
商业和零售的概念。没有商店。没有商店。没有实体店。这只是你试图以某种方式捕获人们的注意力。而你拥有的唯一工具就是音频、视频、电影、图像、文本，以及能够发送该信息的不同渠道。这就是你拥有的全部。因此，为了发送社交媒体优化，比如在 Twitter 上，像评论之类的，它非常相似，尽管它可能更简单，因为你没有那么多需要解决的不同目标。而且它的风险也没有那么高。如果我弄错了，大多数时候，它不会花费任何人任何需要他们随后承担责任的金钱，这与电子商务网站不同，如果我一直弄错，那么要么我会向人们收取从未交付的广告收入的费用，要么人们因为没有找到他们想要的东西而不买。
media optimization, like on Twitter, like comments and such, it's very similar, although it may be simpler because you don't have as many different objectives that you're trying to solve for. And it's not as high stakes. Like if I get it wrong, most of the time, it's not costing anybody any amount of money that they're then going to be accountable for, which is different than let's say an e-commerce site where if I'm consistently getting it wrong, then well, either I'm going to charge people for like ads revenue that never delivered or people don't buy because they didn't find what they were looking for.
所以风险更高。但试图捕获注意力然后衡量它并以某种方式对其进行优化的总体概念，这个循环，就是运行 Facebook、运行亚马逊、运行 Google 以及运行 Promoted AI 所做的事情的核心基本循环。好的。所以，好吧，再次强调，那里有很多非常好的观察。我认为这是一个非常有趣的方式。我不知道你有时是否会听到这样的话，即它是一个注意力市场，或者他们在购买你的注意力，或者在出售你的时间。你听到这种说法通常带有对社交媒体或广告商的某种贬义。但我的意思是，我认为，你一开始就说过，这只是一件抽象的事情。你在看手机，
So the stakes are higher. But the general concept of trying to capture attention and then measure it and then optimize for it in some way, that loop, that's the core fundamental loop that runs Facebook, that runs Amazon, that runs Google and runs what promoted AI does as well. Okay. So, all right, again, again, a bunch of really good observations there. I think that's a really interesting way. I don't know that you hear about that sometimes that it's an attention marketplace, or they're buying your attention or selling your time. You hear about this in a almost derogatory sense against social media or against advertisers. But I mean, I think it, you kind of said at the beginning, it's just an abstract thing. You're looking at your phone,
最终某些东西甚至连手机本身都在决定，嘿，我是要为你启动这个应用呢？还是要把你带到，你知道的，你手机上的浏览器或其他什么地方？每个人都在试图优先考虑他们认为你想要的、或者他们认为你喜欢的、或者能让你不断回来的东西。你说得对。这是一个更加通用的东西，甚至开车也是如此。什么在争夺你的注意力？是出口的标志，还是当地餐馆的标志，或者是街头闪烁着灯光的豪华酒店？每个人都在争夺你注意力的一部分。我认为这很有趣。
ultimately something is being the phone itself is even deciding, hey, am I going to offer to launch this app for you? Or am I going to send you to, you know, your browser on your phone or whatever? Like everybody is sort of trying to prioritize what they think you want or what they think you like or what will keep you coming back. Like you're right. It's a much more generic thing, even driving down the road. what vies for your attention? Is it the signs for the exit or the signs for the local restaurant or the fancy hotel flashing its lights down the street? Everybody's sort of vying for a piece of your attention. And I think that's interesting.
我不知道我是否觉得这本质上是恶意的。这就是现实。这就是生活运作的方式。我觉得它好像一直都是这样的。哦，这几乎就像是大声说出不言而喻的事实，很多时候这并不是人们明确考虑的事情，直到它变得具有对抗性，直到它变得像一个广告，像一个令人讨厌的、打断性的广告，它是如此明确，以至于它需要你的注意力，哦，有人，有人在偷走我的注意力，但仅靠产品设计本身。那是在平衡你的注意力。我不知道在
I don't know that I find it inherently malicious. That's a thing. It's just the way life works. I feel like it's kind of always been that way. Oh, it's almost like just saying the quiet thing out loud it's a lot of the times it's not something people explicitly think about until it becomes adversarial until it becomes like an advertisement like an obnoxious interrupting advertisement that is so explicit that it demands your attention oh someone, someone is stealing my attention, but just product design by itself. That's balancing your attention. I don't know in the
过去，如果你开过特斯拉汽车，现在你开始体验到，哦，不，在那一个屏幕上有那么多不同的、争夺你注意力的东西。但这些东西都不是广告或商业性质的。这只是一种注意力经济，你只有有限的注意力，你需要专注于完成你的任务。每当你打开手机并浏览电子商务网站或市场时，也是同样的道理。因此，市场方面使其变得非常明确，你正在利用这一点，而不是像更普遍的争夺你的注意力以及所有你可以做的事情或者所有可以出现在你屏幕上的东西那样，它更像是一个聚焦的元素，这里是一个特定的目的地。在这个目的地，我应该向你展示什么来帮助你完成你的
last, if you've ever driven a Tesla car, now you're starting to experience, oh no, you have so many different competing things for your attention on that, on that one screen. But none of these things are ads or commercial. It's just, there's an attention economy of you have a limited amount of attention you need to focus on accomplishing your tasks. And it's the same concept of every time you open your phone and navigate to an e-commerce site or a marketplace. So the marketplace aspect is making it quite explicit where you're taking this as opposed to like the more general sense of competing for your attention and like everything that you could be doing or like everything that could be on your screen, it's more of a focused element here of here's a specific destination. And what should I show you at this destination to help you accomplish your
目标？如果你是一个买家，或者如果你是一个卖家，我如何捕获人们注意力的这种传入资源来完成你的目标，这些目标通常是，我想出售某种产品或传达我的信息并被找到。所以针对那个具体的评论，我的意思是，你认为两者之间有区别吗？所以你刚才说，专注于市场，当我觉得市场时，你是为了一个特定的，嗯，也许不是全部。但在许多情况下，你提到，你知道，你想去 hip camp，或者你想去，我猜甚至像 eBay，你输入，我想买一种东西。
goals? If you're a buyer or if you're a seller, like how do I capture this incoming resource of people's attention to accomplish your objectives, which are typically, I want to sell some sort of product or communicate my message and be found. So on that specific comment, I mean, do you think there's a difference between so you were saying, you know, focusing on marketplaces, when I feel like a marketplace, you're going for a specific, well, maybe not all of them. But in many cases, you mentioned, like, you know, you want to go to hip camp, or you want to go to, I guess, even like eBay, you enter, I want to buy a kind of thing.
你想要什么非常具体，而如果我打开 Facebook，或者我只是，我猜去亚马逊的主页，我的意图很不清楚，比如我对什么具体的东西感兴趣。你认为当人们表达特定的意图时，与他们只是说“嘿，我在这里，给我看点东西”之间有什么区别吗？哦，从技术的角度来看，在实现方式上存在一些差异，但它仍然是一个总体概念，即你只有一个屏幕，鉴于你拥有的信号，你将如何捕获某人的注意力或更好地实现或完善他们正在寻找的东西。所以在像搜索这样的情况下，哦，现在我知道他们输入了这个搜索查询，
And it's very specific what you're wanting, versus if I open Facebook, or I just, you know, I guess go to the homepage of Amazon, it's very unclear what my intention is, like what specific I'm interested for. Do you think there's kind of a difference between when people are expressing a specific intent and when they're just saying hey I'm here like show me something oh from a technology perspective there are some differences in terms of how it's implemented but it's still a general it's the same concept of you have one screen and how are you going to capture someone's attention or best fulfill or refine what they're looking for given the signals that you have. So in the case of like a search, oh, now I know that they've put in this search query,
但该搜索查询周围可能有大量的上下文，可以帮助你细化，好吧，这是我想要展示的不同结果。对于像主页信息流（home feed）这样的情况，它的针对性较少，但你仍然在试图弄清楚，为了捕获某人的注意力或以可操作的方式细化它，什么是最好的可能结果。因此，对于 Promoted AI 的技术，我们实际上是以相同的方式对这两件事进行建模的。我们只是改变了检索集。所以就像，好吧，如果它像一个主页信息流，那么检索集将是诸如热门项目之类的事情，或者是你以前与之交互过的类别的东西，或者可能是一些顶级促销活动
but there could be a tremendous amount of context around that search query that would help you refine, okay, here are the different results that I want to show. For like a home feed, it's less directed, but you're still trying to figure out, well, what's the best possible results to capture someone's attention or refine it in a way that it can be actionable. And so for the technology, for promoted AI, we literally model these two things the same. We just change the retrieval set. So it's like, well, if it's like a home feed, then the retrieval set will be things like popular items or things that are of a category that you've interacted with before, or like maybe like some top promotions
或类似的东西。然后对于搜索查询，它是可以的。它至少必须与搜索查询相关。然后你在该集合内工作。但是允许显示的东西的通用技术。现在我想在该集合中找到最佳匹配并衡量结果。这里的下一个反馈循环是相同的。好的，太棒了。所以，是的，让我们看看那个循环可能是怎样的。我记不住术语了，
or something like that. And then for a search query, it's okay. It has to be at least relevant to the search query. And then you work within that set. But the general technology of here's the things that are allowed to be shown. And now I want to, within that set, find the best matches and then measure the results. And the next feedback loop here is the same. Okay, awesome. So yeah, let's see how maybe that loop. So I won't get the terms right
但你提到了这个类似于排名的想法，你有所有这些可能的结果，你根据某种分数对它们进行排名，所以像，确定如何排名和给候选集中的所有东西打分时，会涉及哪些因素，是的，这是 Promoted AI 独有的东西，或者说是我们关注的东西，而不是一般情况。在一般情况下，它只是一些质量分数。如果它更好，它就会排在顶部。对于 Promoted AI 来说，这正在进入解决市场问题，
but you kind of mentioned this idea of like rankings you have all these possible results and you're ranking them and you're ranking them according to some score yeah so like is what is what are kind of some of the things that go into determining how you rank and how you score all of the things that are in your candidate yeah this is something unique to promoted ai or something that we we focus on as opposed to in general. In general, it's just some kind of quality score. And then if it's better, it's at the top. For promoted AI, and this is getting into the solving the marketplace problem,
我们试图做的是，字面意思上预测某人与每个单个项目交互的可能性，然后是某种后续动作？它是否导致某人采取行动？而且它不仅限于单个项目。你可以想象它也是整个组合。例如，如果你展示，假设你喜欢，如果你稍微喜欢红色，但也可能喜欢蓝色，而我向你展示的全是红色项目，那可能不是最佳组合。也许它是红色和蓝色的混合。所以
what we're trying to do is literally predict what's the likelihood of someone interacting with each individual item and then some sort of subsequent action? Did it cause somebody to make an action? And it's not just at individual items. You imagine it's the entire composition as well. So for example, if I show you, if let's say you like, like you slightly like red, but maybe you also like blue and I show you all red items that may not be the best composition. Maybe it's like a mixture of red and blue. So
对于排名概念，首先你想要好的项目，但随后你还需要将这些项目组合成最佳结果集。然后你试图为一个用户最大化，他们是否采取了某种期望的行动？他们成功了吗？这通常是某种购买决定，比如他们是否成功完成了购买？这不一定非要在每个单独的项目上。它只是整体组合。所以我们这样做的方式是，我们试图首先预测，就像一个一般的质量分数。然后你通过组合这个最大组合来稍后对其进行细化。比如，如何在给定较小的高质量项目集（可能是一个很好的匹配）的情况下，最大化购买概率？
for the ranking concept, it's more first you want good items, but then you also need to compose these items together into the best result set. And then you're trying to maximize for a user, did they take some sort of desired action? Were they successful? And usually that's some sort of purchase decision, like did they successfully complete a purchase? And it doesn't necessarily have to be on each individual item. It's just the overall composition. So the way that we do this is we are trying to predict the first, just like a general quality score. And then you refine it later by composing this maximum composition. Like what's, how do I maximize the probability of a purchase given that a smaller set of high quality items that are probably a good match?
所以这有点像，如果你的结果集太相似了，人们不会感觉到有，也许我太抽象了，但如果它们太相似了，人们不会觉得有多样性，没有丰富度，而如果你展示几个多样化的项目，即使你认为它们单独来看可能不是最好的结果，你也在让用户知道，嘿，这里有很多丰富度。是的，这里还有其他一些方面，也就是你有其他目标。所以这回到了我们一开始谈论的内容，即你有三个具有不同目标的不同的方。你有买家或消费者。
So it's like some amount of, if your result set was too similar and people don't get an idea that there's, and maybe I'm being too abstract, but if they're too similar, people don't get a feel that there's like a diversity, there isn't a richness versus if you show a few diverse items even if you think individually they wouldn't be the best result then you're letting the user know hey there's a lot of richness here yes is it like yep there's some other aspects here too which is you have other objectives so this is getting back to what we were talking about in the beginning where you have three different parties with different objectives. You have the buyer or like the consumer.
然后你还有卖家或内容所有者，然后你还有市场本身。例如，你需要确保你所有的卖家或所有的内容生产者都获得一定数量的曝光。如果你只提供最受欢迎的内容，那么你就会遇到饥饿问题，即你永远不会有任何新内容浮出水面，这对于那些永远不会获得任何交付的创建新内容的人来说是糟糕的，但最终对用户来说也变得糟糕。他们只是不知道。就像现在今天一样，它更像是一个
Then you also have the sellers or like who the content owners, and then you have the marketplace itself. So for example, you want to make sure that all of your sellers or all of your content producers get some amount of exposure. And if you agree to lead just giving the most popular contents, then you have the starvation problem where you're never getting new contents ever surfaced, which is terrible for people who are creating new contents, never get any delivery, but also eventually becomes bad for users. They just don't know about it. Like literally right now today, it's more of like a
长期的挑战。因此，你试图解决的另一件事不仅是今天针对这个特定实例的最佳用户体验，甚至还要考虑像这种组合方面，比如多样性，你还要解决卖家体验。每个卖家都需要获得一定数量的轮换，否则你就会把他们饿死，这会导致未来的长期问题，即你不再有任何生产者。然后你还面临市场挑战，即如果这是一个商业市场，你要么分得销售额的一部分。因此，这里需要考虑的是这能带来多少利润（如果有的话），或者如果它更像是一个注意力市场（比如社交媒体），你必须展示一些广告，因为那是你的业务。好吧，你展示哪些广告，展示多少，以及在你开始以牺牲用户体验的方式进行权衡之前，你会让人感到多么讨厌，
long-term challenge. And so another thing that you're trying to solve for is not just today for this specific instance, the best user experience, and even accounting for like this composition aspect, like diversity, you're also solving for the seller experience. Like each seller needs to get some amount of rotation or else you starve them out, which causes this long-term problem in the future where you don't have any producers anymore. And then you also have the marketplace challenge, which is if it's a commercial marketplace, you either are making a fraction of the sale. So there's a consideration of how much profit is this, if any, or if it's more of like an intention marketplace, like social media, you have to show some ads because that's your business. Well, which ads do you show and how many and like, how obnoxious are you going to make it before you start trading off user experience in a way that
以至于人们干脆停止使用你的产品。所以这不仅是找到最好的内容，也是内容的最佳组合。然后你还有卖家的其他长期考虑，比如卖家需要有好的匹配。即使那里有一些权衡，也是为了获得一些长期目标的轮换。然后对于市场来说，它是你将如何把这个变成一项业务，你将如何从中赚钱，
people just stop using your product. So it's not just finding the best contents, but it's also the best composition of contents. And then you have other longer-term considerations of the sellers, like sellers need to have good matches. And even if there's like some trade-offs there is to get some rotation for longer-term objectives. And then for the marketplace, it's how are you going to make this into a business and how are you going to make money from it?
并为此进行建模。而 Promoted AI 处理这一点的方式是，当我们在做出这些决定时，我们试图用实际美元或某种绝对单位来量化它们。所以这不仅仅是关于，嘿，这是最佳组合。这是这个组合的价值。如果你偏离了这一点，比如这是我最好的可能用户体验，如果我偏离了最佳可能用户体验，这个价值目标的差异是什么？然后你把它转换成美元。所以你
And then modeling for that. And the way promoted AI deals with this is when we're making these decisions, we're trying to quantify them in actual dollars or some sort of absolute unit. So it's not just about, hey, this is the best composition. It's here's the value of this composition. And if you deviate from that, like if here's my best possible user experience, and if I deviate from the best possible user experience, what's the difference in this value objective? And then you convert that into dollars. So you're
创造的不仅仅是解决最佳结果，而是你多么想要那个最佳结果，以便你可以在三个不同的方之间进行这些单位转换并最大化这个目标并进行权衡。是的，这真的很有趣。我的意思是，这可能有点离题，我们可以回来，但当你\$说你对所有东西都按美元定价时，其中一些是短期的，比如用户会点击并购买这个东西吗？是的。其中一些是，用户会高兴并返回市场吗？
creating, you're not just solving the best result, but how much you want that best result so that you can do these sort of unit conversions and maximize this objective across three different parties and do trade-offs. Yeah, it's really interesting. I mean, this may be a bit off topic and we can return, but when you say you price everything in dollars, but some of it is the short term, like will the user click and buy this thing? Yeah. And some of it, will the user be happy and return to the marketplace?
是的。但其中一个是今天的美元，另一个是明天的美元。比如，你必须进行权衡，比如资金的时间价值，并说用户在未来一年的终身价值与今天捕获这笔资金相比？是的。是的，你必须这样做。顺便说一句，它可能并没有字面上以美元建模。我认为这更像是一种抽象。但从数学的角度来看，如果你在运营一个商业市场，那么是的，确实如此。单位会换算成美元。因此，你必须有意识地认识到，你正在这些决策权衡中贴上美元符号。所以我们发现，明确承认这一点并尝试对其进行建模，总比只有每个杠杆却瞎胡闹、根本不仔细考虑要好。
Yeah. But one of those is like today dollars and And one of them is tomorrow dollars. Like, do you have to do a trade off like time value of money and say like a user's lifetime value over the next year versus capturing this amount of money today? Yes. Yeah, you have to. And by the way, it may not be literally modeled in dollars. I think that's more of a abstraction. But from the math of it, if you are running a commercial marketplace, then yeah, it does. The units will work out to dollars. So you have to be conscientious that you are putting a dollar sign on these decision trade-offs. So we find it's better to explicitly acknowledge that and try to model with it versus just kind of having each lever and kind of goofing around with it and not thinking about it so carefully.
但是，是的，长期收入与短期收入之间存在权衡，或者说短期体验与长期体验之间存在权衡。这就是艺术与科学开始融合的地方，有时你永远无法准确衡量这些事情。或者如果你看看美元符号，它并不完全吻合，但它仍然是正确的产品体验。你确实需要有一些人在回路中来弄清楚，好吧，这对我在此时此刻是正确的权衡吗，或者实际体验是什么？但这并不意味着你不应该尝试量化它。你绝对应该关注它。你绝对应该刻意去做。但这并不意味着你会得到某种完美的机器，
But yes, there is a trade-off of long versus short-term revenue or like short-term experience versus long-term experience. And this is where the art and the science start to merge, where sometimes you will never be able to exactly measure these sorts of things. Or like if you look at the dollar signs, it doesn't quite line up, but it's still the right product experience. You do have to have some human in the loop to figure out, OK, is this the right tradeoff for me at this time or what is the actual experience? But that doesn't mean you shouldn't try to quantify it. You should definitely be watching it. You should definitely do it on purpose. But that doesn't mean you're going to get like some sort of perfect machine
一切都经过精确建模，这根本不是任何系统中的经济学运作方式，当然也不是某种长期用户偏好建模的运作方式。所以，我不是一个靠机器学习背景吃饭的人，但鉴于你的名字里有 AI，并且假设你使用机器学习，我觉得这是一个很好的猜测，
where everything is exactly modeled. Like that's just not how economics works in any system and definitely not like some sort of long-term user preference sort of modeling. So I'm not a machine learning background person by trade, but given that you have AI in the name and assuming you use machine learning, which I feel like is a good guess,
你开始谈论这种让新卖家挨饿并需要向他们展示的现象。这让我想起，我猜，那种试图平衡探索与利用（exploitation）之间不断进行的恒定事物的例子，你赌场大厅里有一排老虎机，它们都有略微不同的赔率，你不知道该去哪一个，所以你走到你的第一个，拉了一下，中了大奖。好吧，你难道就一遍又一遍地玩那同一个吗？答案是数学上来说
you started talking about this starving out new sellers and needing to show them. And it reminds me of, I guess, the example where trying to balance this constant thing between exploration voice versus exploitation and you have a bank of slot machines on the casino floor and they all have a slightly different payout and you don't know which one to go to so you go to your first one you pull and you get a jackpot well do you just keep playing that same one over and over again and the answer is like mathematically
不是的，因为在其他地方可能有一个赔率更好的（你知道的）或者更高概率的机器，如果不以一定的概率继续尝试所有这些机器，你就不会拥有它。所以你能稍微谈谈，比如，显然其中一部分可能涉及核心机密（secret sauce），我们不能真正谈论到底发生了什么，但从对机器学习的粗浅理解来看，你们是如何获取用于弄清楚如何构建模型的数据的？你们是如何训练模型的？重点是，支撑你们所说的一切背后的技术究竟是什么？哦，是的，好问题，不，我很高兴你提出了汤普森采样（Thompson sampling）的部分，我确实相信有时这些试图以更像教科书的方式解决，而这并不是实际操作中的做法。
no because there might be one with even a better payout you know somewhere else or higher probability and by not continuing to try all of them with some probability you won't have that so can you speak a little bit about like i mean obviously some of it probably gets into secret sauce and you know we can't really talk about exactly what goes on but from a you know a kind of a rudimentary understanding of machine learning how do you guys sort of get in the data that you use to figure out how to build your models how are you training models the point like what is sort of the technology that you guys have going on behind all of what you're saying oh yeah great questions no i love you brought up the thompson sampling part i do believe that sometimes these are tried to be solved in more like a textbook way, which isn't how it's done
因为想象一下汤普森采样的挑战，但就像，你不断地有新的老虎机，而且所有的老虎机也都在变化。你不知道。听起来容易多了。所以，是的， exatamente（没错）。我们处理它的方式是，首先，我们拥有整套指标基础设施，其中任何形式的优化，我认为这是人们从机器学习中遗漏的另一个要素，在实践中，机器学习的大部分是测量和数据基础设施。然后机器学习在实践中的下一部分是机器学习运维，比如事情出错了，你需要修复它并知道它出错了。
in practice. Because imagine that the Thompson sampling challenge, but like, you're constantly getting new slot machines, and all the slot machines are also changing. And you don't know. It sounds easier. So yeah, exactly. The way that we handle it is first, we have a whole metrics infrastructure, where any sort of optimization, and I think this is another element that people miss out from machine learning, like in practice, most of machine learning is measurement and data infrastructure. And then the next part of machine learning in practice is machine learning operations, like stuff goes wrong and you need to fix it and know that it's wrong.
解决这两件事几乎可以解决所有问题。我的意思是，这并不是什么秘密。去吧。我的意思是，工程部分就体现在这里。这很难。建模本身并没有那么复杂。事实上，如果你看看，嗯，它可能会变得复杂。一旦你有了基础，你就可以开始真正堆砌各种复杂的机器学习、神经网络，然后你就会进入像 Facebook 和 Google 这样的世界级公司。但是，正确衡量正在发生的事情，并能够可靠地收集这些数据并在近乎实时的情况下作出反应，几乎可以帮你解决所有最难的部分。所以我们正在做的是，我们正在衡量应该展示什么。展示了什么？有人真的看到了吗？顺便说一句，这很有挑战性，比如，想想看。你是怎么看到的？
And solving those two things will get you almost all of the problem. I mean, that's no secret. Go for it. I mean, that's where the engineering part comes in. It's hard. The modeling itself is not that complicated. In fact, if you look at, well, it can get complicated. Once you have the basics in place, then you can start really piling on all sorts of complicated machine learning, neural networks, and you get into Facebooks and Googles of the world. But just correctly measuring what's happening and being able to collect that data reliably and react on it in like near real time gets you almost all of the hard part. So what we're doing is we're measuring what was supposed to be shown. What was shown? Did someone actually see it? Which by the way, is challenging where like, think about it. Like how did you see
解决这两件事基本上就解决了绝大部分问题。我的意思是，这并不是什么秘密。去干吧。我的意思是，这就是工程学发挥作用的地方。这很难。建模本身并没有那么复杂。事实上，如果你看看——嗯，它也可能会变复杂。一旦你有了基础，你就可以开始真正堆砌各种复杂的机器学习、神经网络，然后你就会进入像Facebook和Google这样的公司。但只要准确测量正在发生的事情，并能够可靠地收集这些数据，并在接近实时的情况下做出反应，你就几乎克服了所有最困难的部分。所以我们正在做的是，我们测量了应该展示什么。展示了什么？真的有人看到它了吗？顺便说一句，这很有挑战性，比如，想想看。比如你是怎么看到它的
it? Did you not see it? There's all sorts of streaming signals. And you just turn on the camera and you look at their gaze, right? Like there don't do that but anyways like did someone see it did they click on it by the way oh my gosh like if you get the details someone in mobile engineering like what does a click mean on a mobile oh gosh like did they buy it did like how long ago did they buy it like just measuring what people did reliably. And now you have reliable metric stream. Now you're going to try to predict back that metric stream. And you're going to try to do it in a way of attributing it back to, was someone's action caused by them seeing something on some surface that you can control? So like search results or feed, if it wasn't caused
吗？你没看到吗？各种流式信号都有。你只要打开摄像头，观察他们的视线，对吧？别那样做——总之，有人看到了吗？顺便问一下，他们点击了吗？天哪，如果你获取细节，比如移动工程部门的人，移动端上的“点击”到底意味着什么？天哪，他们购买了吗？他们是多久前购买的？——这只是为了可靠地衡量人们的行为。现在你有了可靠的指标流。接下来你要尝试预测这个指标流，并将其归因：某个人的行动是否是由他们看到你在某个可控的界面上展示的内容引起的？比如搜索结果或信息流，如果不是由它引起的，
by it, then changing it won't cause that to go up more. So that's another important part of you need this sort of causal estimate of you seeing something that you can change caused some sort of future action. And if you don't measure that part, like you just take all the actions together, then you won't be able to have a training set that you can train a model to cause someone to do something else. So it's causal measurement. Now you have the training examples to then try and make people do more of the thing you want them to do and less of the thing you don't want them to do, like typically leave or not complete some sort of. So you're predicting want them to do, like typically leave or not complete some sort of.
那么改变它也不会让那个指标上升更多。所以这是另一个重要部分：你需要一种因果估计，即你看到某些你可以改变的东西，从而引发了某种未来的行动。如果你不衡量这一部分，比如你把所有行动混为一谈，你就无法获得一个训练集来训练一个模型，从而促使人们去做某事。这就是因果衡量。现在你有了训练样本，就可以尝试让人多做你希望他们做的事，少做你不希望他们做的事，比如通常的离开或未能完成某种操作。所以你在预测人们想要做的——比如通常的离开或未能完成某种操作。
So you're predicting for the next search results or feed results or the next thing you're going to show in this sort of featured area, what is going to cause this metric stream to create the objective, which is usually some sort of purchase. What's the maximum probability for that? What's the result set that will maximize that probability
所以你在为下一次的搜索结果、信息流结果，或者接下来要在这个推荐区域展示的内容进行预测：什么样的事能够促使这个指标流产生目标，通常这就是某种购买行为。达到这个目标的最高概率是什么？什么样结果集能最大化这个概率？
considering these other things of like exploration. So the way that we handle it is it's like layers of models on models on models on models. So like you start with like a simple model for retrieval. Like, is it relevant? Like, is it allowed to be shown? And then you have a next set for, okay, assuming every single item could be placed first, what's the probability in isolation? What's the probability that someone is going to click and then convert on this item? And then once you have like a smaller set, then you say, all right, for all these top sets,
同时还要考虑探索等其他因素。我们处理它的方式是层层叠加的模型，即模型套模型。所以你从一个简单的检索模型开始。比如，它相关吗？它被允许展示吗？然后是下一组，假设每一个商品都可以排在第一位，孤立来看它的概率是多少？有人点击并在这个商品上转化的概率是多少？一旦你有了一个较小的集合，你就会说，好的，对于所有这些顶部的集合，
I want to maximize my composition. And I have these rules about, okay, diversity of like, say different categories, or I have some sort of exploration rule where I'm purposely inserting some new items and sort of maximize within that. And then like the idea of diversity, like how much diversity or how much boosting? Well, that's another model on top of this, which is, okay, given all of the data that I've seen, it's like a feature that you can tune according to here are lots of different users here's what the results were like come up with an estimate for the ideal amount of diversity for like here's generally the conversion probability but also things like marketplaces will have a
我要最大化我的组合。并且我有这些规则，比如不同类别的多样性，或者我有某种探索规则，即我刻意插入一些新商品并在其中进行最大化。然后关于多样性的理念，需要多少多样性或多少提升？这又是叠加在上面的另一个模型，即：鉴于我看到的所有数据，这是一个可以根据以下情况进行调整的特征：这里有很多不同的用户，结果是什么样的——从而为理想的多样性量给出估计，比如这里通常的转化概率，但同时像市场这样的地方也会有
concept of some sort of like seller objective like they want some amount of seller success new seller success like how much diversity does that take? Or how much boosting does that take to be able to accomplish that sort of business objective of seller success or new seller success? And if you have ads, then now you're doing a trade-off, which, okay, I'm going to remove some user quality. I'm going to insert something else. So how much is it worth it to that advertiser to be inserted, which is usually some sort of estimate of click or conversion and then their bid. And then like the user experience, like I've displaced some amount of that user value that we've estimated in, I guess, a couple of steps
某种卖家目标的概念，比如他们希望达到一定数量的卖家成功、新卖家成功——这需要多少多样性？或者为了实现这种卖家成功或新卖家成功的商业目标，需要进行多少提升？如果你有广告，那么现在你就在做一个权衡，即：我要移除一些用户体验质量，插入别的东西。那么对该广告主来说，被插入值多少钱，这通常是点击或转化的一种估计以及他们的出价。然后是用户体验，我替代了一定数量的用户价值，我们在几个步骤前刚刚估算过，
ago, I had just talked about convert it into dollars. And then if the bid exceeds that lost value, show it. And if not, don't show it. That's how it's done. It's like every level you're trying to come up with, this is what this system is trying to accomplish, come up with some objective. And then the next layer will use that output from the previous system as an input to come up with some sort of higher level objective. And then the whole thing is being continuously tuned, measured, and optimized with this real-time streaming data that is checking to see, oh, well, the model yesterday thought it was X, but now it's starting to drift more towards Y, so you need to make these adjustments. This thing you said about metrics,
我刚才谈到将其转换为美元。然后，如果出价超过了损失的价值，就展示它；如果没有，就不展示。这就是它的运作方式。在每一个层级，你都试图得出：这个系统想要完成什么，设定一个目标。然后下一层将使用前一个系统的输出作为输入，来得出某种更高层级的目标。整个过程都在通过这种实时流数据进行持续的调整、衡量和优化，这些数据会检查：哦，昨天的模型认为它是X，但现在它开始更多地向Y漂移，所以你需要进行这些调整。你刚才说关于指标的事，
I think is as a bit of an aside, I don't know like if it's just a bad word or people, but this ability to say that you know that your code is doing the thing it was supposed to do or that the thing you wanted to happen, I feel is undervalued or under thought about that I see this,
我觉得这有点像题外话，我不知道这是否是一个不好的词或者人们怎么看，但我认为这种能够证明你的代码正在做它理应做的事情、或者你希望发生的事情的能力，被低估了，或者说人们思考得不够，我发现这一点，
not just in the domain we're talking about but just even stuff i do that's completely unrelated people miss that this you know you always make that joke where someone says it the code compiled it's done but i would say people even say oh it runs and it's done and it's not just like unit testing i mean maybe that's one way yeah but even just whole stack tracking like hey the code is supposed to accomplish this goal. Like, are you actually measuring it? Are you actually saying, is the output reasonable? Are you monitoring it? Are you recording it?
不仅在我们讨论的领域，甚至在我做的其他完全无关的事情中，人们都会忽视这一点。你知道，你总会开玩笑说有人会说“代码编译通过了，搞定”。但我想说，人们甚至会说“它运行起来了，搞定”，而且这不仅仅指单元测试——也许那是其中一种方式，是的，但甚至是全栈追踪，比如“嘿，这段代码理应实现这个目标。你真的在衡量它吗？你真的在说输出合理吗？你在监控它吗？你在记录它吗？”
And I think people don't, they try to tack it on at the end rather than saying, like, this is something we need to build in that we're monitoring the health of the system. I think part of it is, it's painful. It's really, it's not fun for a lot of the times. It's not sexy. It's not like directly accomplishing some sort of business goal in the sense of like, oh, I'm going to apply machine learning and I'm going to get 10% more conversions. Like fantastic. Great.
我认为人们没有这样做，他们试图在最后才把这个补上去，而不是说：这是我们需要内置的东西，我们需要监控系统的健康状况。我想部分原因是，这很痛苦。真的，很多时候这并不好玩。它不够性感。它不像直接实现某种商业目标那样，比如“哦，我要应用机器学习，我要获得多10%的转化率”。太棒了，很好。
But what are you going to apply it on? And how do you know it's still working? Oh, well well that's not directly accomplishing my goal right so i think people love to jump straight to the sexy piece because it's a little bit on the nose of oh yes i want my objective to go up so i'm going to do the thing that makes my objective go up but the measurement part that's really challenging because you have to look at the nitty gritty of, Oh no front.
但你要把它应用在什么上面？你怎么知道它还在起作用？哦，那并不能直接实现我的目标，对吧？所以我认为人们喜欢直接跳到性感的部分，因为它直击要害：“哦，是的，我希望我的目标上升，所以我要做能让我的目标上升的事情。”但衡量部分真的很具挑战性，因为你必须关注细枝末节，哦，没有前端。
If you're back in like, Oh no front end code. And, you know, and then you have to like log at some place and then it needs to be continuously streaming. And that's a really challenging problem. Or like you just said it to what I've seen those people just punt and just
如果你在后端，哦，没有前端代码。然后你必须在某个地方记录日志，然后它需要持续流式传输。这是一个极具挑战性的问题。或者就像你刚才说的，我见过的那些人只是直接放弃，然后
send it to snowflake. And then it's sort of like snowflakes problem, but then you have to build on, you still have to do something with the data. Yeah, you know, if you're doing any kind of optimization or maximization, and you want to do it quantitatively, don't you think it's an important part to measure it correctly first
把它发送到Snowflake。然后这就成了Snowflake的问题，但你仍然得对这些数据做点什么。是的，你知道，如果你在做任何形式的优化或最大化，并且你想以定量的方式去做，难道你不认为首先正确地衡量它是一个重要的部分吗？
and make sure that like what you're trying to maximize is like you have it, like you know what it is. And surprisingly, people don't think that way. What they like to hear is like, hey, like you know what it is and surprisingly people don't think that way what they like to hear is like hey we have machine learning bring your own data and you can just plug in your own data and then our magical machine learning will just figure it out well okay and the very best case the whatever the machine learning is going to do is going to reproduce your crappy measurement which is going to be worthless because it's not instrumented well, and it's not very well coverage. And there's all sorts of biases and gaps. Well, what's the value of that? But like
并确保你试图最大化的东西是你所掌握的，你知道它是什么。出乎意料的是，人们不这么想。他们喜欢听的是：“嘿，你知道它是什么——出乎意料的是，人们不这么想，他们喜欢听的是：‘嘿，我们有机器学习，带上你自己的数据，你可以直接接入你自己的数据，然后我们神奇的机器学习就会搞定它。’”好吧，好吧，在最好的情况下，无论机器学习要做什么，它都会复制你糟糕的测量结果，这将毫无价值，因为它没有被很好地埋点，
you could say, look, we did machine learning. Anyways, getting back to your original prompt of how do you feel about measurement, Andrew? It's critical. And it's not just like the data signals, but also things like, are you correctly measuring things? Like, did this cause this other thing? I think if you start talking to like a growth team or like someone who has to buy ads, they really start getting interested in measurement because it's their butts on the line. If you go to Netflix, for example, they have an enormous marketing science team or Wayfair or a lot of these big companies. They have an enormous data science measurement team. Are my ad campaigns working on Facebook and Google? Because they're spending
覆盖率也不高。而且里面充满了各种偏差和漏洞。那这样做的价值是什么？但你可以说，“看，我们用了机器学习。”无论如何，回到你最初关于你对度量的看法的问题，安德鲁？这至关重要。而且不仅是数据信号，还包括诸如：你是否正确地衡量了事物？比如，这件事是否导致了另一件事？我想如果你开始和增长团队交谈，或者和那些必须购买广告的人交谈，他们真的会对衡量指标产生兴趣，因为这是他们的切身利益所在。如果你去Netflix，例如，他们有一个庞大的营销科学团队，或者Wayfair，或者很多这样的大公司。他们有一个庞大的数据科学衡量团队。我的广告活动在Facebook和Google上起作用了吗？因为他们在
tens of millions or hundreds of millions of dollars on marketing. But then you look at like your own system. So a lot of people work in big tech or like you look at your own marketplace, e-commerce or like your own product. Did you actually produce any of those types of measurements? Like, did you do any of that kind of instrumenting for being able to measure your own thing no you didn't and so like how are you going to optimize on top of it it kind of blows my mind that people don't take the same sort of rigor that they will on their the buy side if like you're going to go build a google adwords campaign and like oh i i must know if this is working look at all the measurement and careful attribution models and like, is it working?
营销上花费了数千万甚至数亿美元。但反观你自己的系统——很多人在大型科技公司工作，或者看看你自己的市场、电商或你自己的产品——你实际上产生过任何此类测量吗？比如，为了能够衡量你自己的产品，你做过任何这样的埋点吗？没有，你没有。那么你将如何在它之上进行优化？这让我有点大跌眼镜，为什么人们在买方市场时不会保持同样的严谨性——如果你要去构建一个Google AdWords广告活动，会觉得“哦，我必须知道这是否有效，看看所有的测量和仔细的归因模型，它管用吗？”
But then you go back to your own product and then like, is your own product working? People are, I will just slap a dash, a couple of things. And then you want to lay on top of machine learning. Good luck. Wow.
但当你回到你自己的产品时，然后你的产品管用吗？人们只会，我随便贴个仪表盘，加上几样东西。然后你就想在上面套用机器学习。祝你好运。哇。
I think we hit a good topic there for a long time. It's good. It's good. I think you're right. I mean, I think a lot of people stuff just works and don't touch what's working. And if it ain't broke, don't fix it. I think people have that.
我觉得我们刚才深入探讨了一个很好的话题，探讨了很长时间。很好，很好。我想你是对的。我的意思是，我认为很多人的东西只要能跑就行，别去碰管用的东西，如果没有坏就不要去修它。我想人们都有这种心态。
They're not measuring it. They're just saying, hey, in the end, it's this number of sales or whatever. And actually, like, introspectively thinking about what's working or why. Even if you're not in a machine learning environment, even like not a huge, big product. I think people, yeah, it's a great insight. even if you're not in a machine learning environment, even like not a huge, big product. I think people, yeah, it's a great insight. So I guess in the position your company is in, where you're sort of saying,
他们没有去衡量它。他们只是说，嘿，归根结底，这就是销售额或者诸如此类的数字。实际上，进行内省式地思考什么在起作用以及为什么起作用——即使你不在机器学习环境中，甚至不是一个非常巨大的产品。我想人们，是的，这是一个极好的见解。即使你不在机器学习环境中，甚至不是一个非常巨大的产品。我想人们，是的，这是一个极好的见解。所以我想在你们公司所处的立场上，你们某种程度上是在说，
we're going to come help you sort of build this, we're going to become experts in the ability of matching buyers and sellers and helping marketplaces, but not be the marketplace yourself. You then have to build into your APIs, the ability for people to hook in their measurements. And then like, how does that work from sort of like marketplace to marketplace, like a lot carry over? Or do you have to start again with each new sort of like integration you guys are doing? Oh, we don't believe in other
我们要来帮你们构建这个，我们将成为撮合买家和卖家的专家，并帮助各个市场，但我们自己并不成为市场。这就要求你们必须在API中构建允许人们接入他们测量数据的功能。然后，从各个市场的角度来看，这通常是怎么运作的？很多东西可以通用吗？还是你们每次做新的集成时都要从头开始？哦，我们不相信别人的
people's measurement. I'll be entirely honest. We provide our own measurement solution and that's where most of the value comes from. We'll help you do the measurement correctly. By the way, when I was at Facebook, I was also in the measurement science group as well. So like I have a lot of background and understanding of like the importance of measurement and data. And then we also have hooks for if you have your own data, you can work it in as well. What we see is that no, it's actually quite generalizable. Like, yes, the exact rules and the data itself are different. But this engine of measure what people see, standardize the path of did people engage with it? Did they convert on it? And then be able to predict that
测量。说实话，我们提供我们自己的测量解决方案，这正是绝大多数价值的来源。我们会帮你把测量做到位。顺便说一下，我在Facebook时，我也在测量科学小组工作。所以我有很多关于测量和数据重要性的背景知识和理解。而且，如果你有自己的数据，我们也有钩子（接口）让你也可以将其整合进来。我们看到的情况是，不，这其实非常具有普适性。是的，确切的规则和数据本身是不同的。但“衡量人们看到的东西，标准化人们是否参与、是否转化的路径，然后能够将这一点预测回来”这个引擎，
back is very generalizable yeah i guess a couple more questions and we'll kind of start to wrap it up we haven't really touched on like you mentioned how important it is for a buyer to know that they're getting the a seller selling an ad the ad buyer i guess that's a two-sided thing yeah it wants to really make sure they're getting their money's worth people who you know purchase something on the marketplace want to know like everybody has this very money's changing hands and people get upset when expectations are unmet right so keeping your platform up working the rankings making sense like all of that how do you guys like treat and like kind of maybe a glimpse inside the back end stack that you guys have set up to sort of make sure that you're reliably accomplishing the the you're stating? Yeah. So before we were talking a little
是非常通用的。是的，我想再问几个问题，我们就要开始收尾了。我们还没有真正触及，就像你提到的，对于一个买家——一个卖家在卖广告，广告买家，我想这是一个双向的事情，是的——他们非常希望确保物有所值。在市场上购买东西的人也想知道，每个人都有真金白银在交易，当期望落空时人们会感到沮丧，对吧？所以保持你的平台正常运行、让排名合理、让这一切——你们如何对待它，能不能稍微透露一下你们搭建的后端技术栈的内部情况，以确保你们可靠地实现了你们所陈述的目标？是的。所以刚才我们讨论了一点
bit about these models stacked on tops of models, and this is really important because each model is supposed to have some objective you can measure, objectively measure. So for example, a click prediction model is predicting clicks. And so the average number of click predictions should equal the actual number of clicks. And you can, that should be globally and for individual items. There's each of these layers have some objective truth that you're comparing it against. And you're checking to make sure are these predictions equal to what's actually happening and if it's not either something is broken or something has like drifted and you need to make a correction so that's a core piece of it the others are from the system design and then like like sre type of pieces of it. So like any kind of abnormality type of detection
关于这些模型叠加在模型之上的事情，这真的很重要，因为每个模型都应该有某种你可以测量、客观测量的目标。例如，点击预测模型就是在预测点击。因此，平均的点击预测次数应该等于实际的点击次数。你可以这样做，这应该是全局的以及针对单个商品的。这些层中的每一层都有一些客观的真理，你可以将其与实际情况进行比较。你在检查这些预测是否等于实际发生的事情，如果没有，要么是哪里坏了，要么是发生了某种漂移，你需要进行纠正。所以这是其中的核心部分，其他部分则来自系统设计以及类似SRE类型的部分。比如任何异常检测类型的组件。
where we have a lot of the different signaling instrumentation for did something suddenly change and why? Like did something break or like was an integration changed? And on our side, we have a shadow traffic tier for our own deployments, but we're also continuously measuring it for our customers as well, because what we see sometimes is someone ships a feature and then that breaks some sort of logging. And if logging is broken, all of what we were just talking about, like in terms of all the system, depending on accurate measurement, then those start to fail. So you want to be able to react
我们有许多不同的信号检测工具来判断：是不是突然发生了什么变化？为什么？比如，是不是有什么东西坏了，或者集成方式改了？在我们的端，针对自身的部署，我们有一个影子流量层，但我们也在持续为客户衡量这些指标，因为我们有时会发现，有人发布了一个功能，结果把某种日志弄坏了。如果日志坏了，我们刚才谈到的所有依赖准确测量的系统都将开始失效。所以你需要能够对此做出非常快速的反应。
to that very quickly. And then another aspect from the marketplace design is it's not all just watching metrics. There has to be some sort of design to it. So for example, this idea of like, how do you know advertisers or like sellers are getting a good deal? Well, you design the system in a way where they're bidding for the objective that they're trying to accomplish. And so long as those predictions are correct, then they're going to be correctly bidding
然后从市场设计（marketplace design）的另一个角度来看，这并不仅仅是盯着指标，其中必须包含某种设计。例如，你怎么知道广告商或卖家买到了划算的交易？嗯，你在设计系统时，让他们为自己试图实现的商业目标去竞价。只要这些预测是准确的，他们就会对最有潜力的机会进行正确的竞价。
for the most promising opportunities. And then from the pricing algorithm, you want it to be designed so that, this is getting more like auction theory piece, you want a dominant strategy type of auction where you want it so that the highest, the optimal strategy is always to bid your true value. And you're trying to set up a system so that it's stable
接着，从定价算法的设计来看，这有点偏向拍卖理论，你希望设计一种占优策略（dominant strategy）类型的拍卖，使得最优策略永远是报出你的真实价值。你试图建立一个稳定的系统，这不仅指计算机系统，还包括经济系统。
and not just like a computer system, but also like the economic system as well. And even some of these are abstract, like people don't know what their true value is, but this idea of like there's exists a single value that's optimal for the best possible competitive ad pricing so that you don't have to then have another system try for every single search result, come up with the correct bid. So like
甚至其中有些概念是抽象的，比如人们可能并不知道自己的真实价值是什么，但这里的意思是：存在一个单一的价值，它对于最佳的、可能的竞争性广告定价来说是最优的，这样你就不用让另一个系统针对每一次搜索结果都去计算出正确的出价。所以，
keeping it all working has an element of watching metrics, making sure that if you're making any kind of predictions or any kind of metrics, they're like, they're streaming in a predictable way. Like there's no sudden changes. And if there are changes, you have either disaster recovery in place, or if it's like a model drift, which is natural, like, hey, there's a new item. And of course, it's new that the models are able to adapt pretty quickly to deal with it. And then there's the system design where the whole economic system altogether is designed in such a way that if everyone is behaving independently the way that they're supposed to, that the overall marketplace is optimizing in a reasonable way. That's some sort of system design that is like how we specialize in building these sorts of things. Yeah, I mean, I think the auction theory and bidding is something people know. Google famously, you know, came up with this. What is the name? Second price? No,
要保持这一切正常运转，既需要观察指标，确保如果你在做任何预测或收集任何指标时，它们都以可预测的方式在传输，没有任何突变。如果有变化，你要么准备好灾难恢复机制，要么如果遇到模型漂移（这是很自然的，比如，嘿，出现了一个新商品，因为它是新的，模型需要能够非常快地适应来处理它）。然后是系统设计，整个经济系统整体的设计方式是：如果每个人都按照他们应有的方式独立行事，那么整个市场就会以一种合理的方式进行优化。这就是某种系统设计，类似于我们专门构建这类东西的方式。是的，我的意思是，我认为拍卖理论和竞价是人们所熟知的。谷歌出名的地方在于，你知道的，他们想出了这个。叫什么名字？第二价格（Second price）？不，
what is it? Oh, man. GSP, generalized second price auction. I hate it. Ah, I did have it. I had it half right. And so I think people kind of maybe have read about this. But like this thing you're saying, which is the optimizations work best when you have the most information and setting up the system so that everyone understands that, hey, this is fair, that there's not a lot of weirdness going on or cheating of the system that someone's doing, getting special handling or treatment allows everything to just run more smoothly. Think of it. I think people get distracted by imagining literal people bidding in an auction
叫什么？哦，天哪。GSP，广义第二价格拍卖（generalized second price auction）。我讨厌它。啊，我其实知道。我猜对了一半。所以我觉得人们可能读到过这方面的文章。但是就像你刚才说的，当你有最多信息时，优化效果最好；同时建立好系统，让每个人都明白，嘿，这是公平的，没有发生什么诡异的事情，也没有人在作弊或享受特殊照顾，这样就能让一切运转得更加顺畅。想想看。我觉得人们会被字面上想象的人们在拍卖中出价的场景所分散注意力，
a little battle is yeah exactly which is not what's happening okay you have even in the google sense which or like a search engine sense where at least you have a search result that you can sort of bid on like a keyword there's it's a bidding interface. You have all of these complicated computer systems actually doing the real bidding and you just have like this itty bitty window. Think of it more as you're designing a computer system, but you want to have compartmentalized systems and numerically you want them compartmentalized. And this is just good software design, but you can also think of this like good software design principle from numerical systems as well. And we talked a little bit about this from the stacking of
进行那种小小的争夺，对，没错，但这并不是实际发生的情况。你看，即使在谷歌的意义上，或者说在搜索引擎的意义上，至少你有一个搜索结果，你可以像对关键词那样进行出价，那里有一个出价界面。实际上是所有这些复杂的计算机系统在真正地进行竞价，而你面对的只有一个极其微小的窗口。把这更多地看作是你在设计一个计算机系统，但你希望有模块化的系统，并且在数值上你也希望它们是模块化的。这不仅是优秀的软件设计，你也可以将此视为来自数值系统的优秀软件设计原则。我们之前稍微讨论过这一点，就是通过堆叠
these different systems where each system has a clear objective that you can objectively measure by itself with objective data. And you can do the same thing from the economic system as well. Like if your bidding interface, if your auction is designed using this quote, dominant strategy idea, then there's only a single value that will maximize for this specific auction. But like, it's not usually, There's like no one with a paddle who's actually trying to do that. You actually have other systems layer on top of each other.
这些不同的系统，其中每个系统都有一个清晰的目标，你可以用客观的数据独立地对它进行客观衡量。从经济系统中你也可以做到这一点。如果你出价的界面、你的拍卖是使用这种所谓的“占优策略”理念设计的，那么对于这个特定的拍卖，将只有一个最大化价值。但是，通常并没有一个拿着小木槌的人在真正做这件事。实际上，是其他系统一层层叠加在彼此之上的。
But what you've done here is you've just removed one extra interaction with other systems so that the overall system is a little bit more stable and able to be tuned better. Whereas this famous GSP Google auction
但你在这里所做的，只是去掉了与其他系统的一个额外交互，从而使整体系统更加稳定，并且能够更好地进行调优。然而像谷歌著名的GSP拍卖
thing, it's so far removed from what they're actually doing. I think they have like 20 or something PhD students just doing nothing, but like messing around with like auction design. There's like so many different pieces to it. It's more of just, Hey, external buyer, it's just a magical black box. And we're just trying to help you accomplish your objective. And ultimately, that's what it becomes is at the Google level. It's here's your bidding interface. And Google is just trying to help you accomplish the maximum amount of your goal while taking as much possible profit as it can, as it feels like it's able to do before people start dropping out of its ad auction. So like,
这种东西，离他们实际在做的事情已经相差太远了。我想他们大概有20个左右的博士生整天什么都不做，就是在那儿琢磨拍卖设计。里面有太多不同的部分了。它更像是：嘿，外部买家，这只是一个神奇的黑盒。我们只是在努力帮你实现你的目标。最终，在谷歌的层面上，它就变成了这样：这是你的出价界面，谷歌只是试图帮你实现最大程度的目标，同时在人们开始退出其广告拍卖之前，尽可能多地获取它认为自己能拿到的利润。所以，
in terms of, hey, Google does GSP, it's so far removed from that. It's not even useful to be thinking about that anymore. Because there's so many different modifications and tweaks. It's more of like, think of it more from like achieving your objective. Awesome. Yeah. I mean, to wrap up, we're gonna talk a little bit about permitted as a company. But before we do that, I know that you were part of a Y Combinator class. And I think Y Combinator has, I'll tout it as like a sort of mythical place in startups and doing your own company and the people associated with it and longevity, which I think has been particularly interesting. So do you mind speaking for a few minutes maybe about nothing in particular? I mean, just what you would share with people or what your experiences were as part of that? Yeah, we did last winter, 20 winter 2021.
就“嘿，谷歌采用的是GSP”而言，这已经相去甚远了。再用这个思路去思考甚至已经没有什么用了。因为有太多不同的修改和微调。它更像是从实现你的目标的角度去思考。太棒了。是的，我的意思是，作为总结，我们接下来要谈谈Promoted这家公司。但在我们讨论之前，我知道你曾是Y Combinator（YC）的一员。我认为Y Combinator在初创企业、自主创业、相关人员以及长盛不衰方面，具有某种神话般的地位，这我觉得尤其有趣。所以你介不介意花几分钟聊聊？其实也没什么特定的主题，就是谈谈你会和大家分享什么，或者你作为其中一员有什么样的经历？是的，我们是去年冬天参加的，2020年冬季批次。
And that was great. Now, as far as a place, no, not anymore. I mean mean i suppose they physically have a place but it was all remote and this was still the peak covid a year ago yeah a year ago my experience of it was it was fantastic i highly recommend it it's expensive at the time they didn't give you as much capital but oh well oh well but it's still like seven percent of your company But I think it's in one sense that it's expensive, but in the other sense, it's a good value in that it solves a lot of the risk of a new startup of you will get some funding. You will get some credibility. You have a network like these sorts of distractions, if you try to do it by yourself, if you can do it by yourself and you know you can and you don't need it, go for it. Like great. But even if you're pretty confident that you can just like having it done for you so you can focus
那段经历很棒。至于说作为一个实体地点，不，现在不是了。我的意思是，我想他们物理上确实有个地方，但当时全是远程的，而且那还是新冠疫情的高峰期，一年前，对，一年前。我对它的体验是：太棒了，我强烈推荐。虽然在当时它成本不低，他们给的资金没那么多，不过也罢，也罢，但它仍然要占你公司百分之七的股份。不过我觉得，一方面它代价不小，但另一方面它物有所值，因为它解决了新初创企业面临的很多风险——你会获得一些资金，你会获得一些信誉，你拥有了一个人脉网络。如果你自己去搞定这些干扰因素，如果你能自己做到，并且你知道自己不需要它，那就去吧，太棒了。但即使你相当自信自己能搞定，有现成的东西帮你处理好，能让你专注于
on building a product and talking to sell users and selling, it's a big time saver. And I do feel like another aspect is the one of the most valuable resources you have as a startup time saver. And I do feel like another aspect is one of the most valuable resources you have as a startup is your time. And especially for later career people who have been in big tech for a few years, your time has a dollar sign now, right? You could be making a million dollars a year doing whatever it is at big tech. So an extra six months of your time screwing around trying to get the best possible seed deal has an opportunity cost of, well, half a million dollars literally doing the math, right?
打造产品、和用户交流以及销售，也能大大节省时间。而且我确实觉得，另一个方面是，作为一家初创企业，你拥有的最宝贵资源之一就是你的时间。特别是对于那些在科技大厂工作过几年的资历较深的职场人来说，你的时间现在是有金钱价值的，对吧？你在大厂不管做什么，一年都能赚一百万美元。因此，白白浪费额外的六个月时间去折腾以争取最好的种子轮融资，其机会成本——用数学算一下的话——字面意思就是五十万美元，对吧？
Like do Y Combinator because you're serious about making your startup work and you want to make it work faster rather than slower because you have other things you could be doing with your life. And there's also a lot of positive effects about helping a startup grow faster rather than slower in terms of momentum. Momentum can only help you. So I recommend it. I also feel that from like a fun perspective, no, it's you sit at your computer and you need to work. things you say are real problems which is like you said every month you take to determine if your startup will succeed or fail has an actual lost opportunity cost to it and so you know moving that moving the ball forward there i guess is a great way of thinking about it i i think again i do believe that for people who are mid later career like you'll see later career people like
所以选择Y Combinator，是因为你真心想要让你的初创企业成功，而且你希望它更快而不是更慢地成功，因为你的生命中还有其他事情要做。而且，就发展势头而言，帮助初创企业更快而不是更慢地成长也有很多积极的影响。势头只会对你有帮助。所以我推荐它。我也觉得从趣味性的角度来看，不，你就是坐在电脑前，你需要工作。你所说的都是真正的问题，正如你所说，你用来决定你的初创企业是成功还是失败的每一个月，都有实际失去的机会成本。所以，推进事情的进展，我猜这是一种很好的思考方式。我再次认为，对于处于职业生涯中期或后期的人来说，你会看到这样的人，
i had a former person in my leadership chain it just went straight to sequoia and they're like okay do series a like look fine if you are like vp of engineering or cto of like a publicly traded company and you can just go straight to sequoia and get like 10 million dollars and go right out of the gate fine but most people probably listening to this podcast like in the general popul okay, are not at that sort of level. Probably if you're at that level, you could just self-fund yourself at $10 million and you don't care. By the way, you'll see that from startup funding. It's like people will give you money you already have.
我领导链条里的前同事，直接去了红杉资本，他们说：“行吧，我们直接做A轮。”好吧，如果你是一家上市公司的工程副总裁（VP of Engineering）或首席技术官（CTO），你可以直接去找红杉资本拿到1000万美元，一出门就把事办了，那也行。但听这个播客的绝大多数普通大众，大概没有达到那种水平。可能如果你达到了那个水平，你就能自己资助自己1000万美元，而且你根本不在乎。顺便说一句，你会从初创企业融资中发现这一点：人们会把钱借给你已经拥有资金的人。
You'll find a lot easier in that sense. Get it done. Like a Y Combinator is a good way to reliably get the earliest, most fragile stages of your company done so that you can get to the next stage, which is finding product market fit. There are other paths, like you can go to the seed funds, they'll get you started. There are other incubators. I don't really recommend other incubators. I don't know why you would do it other than Y Combinator. I think you should just go straight to a seed fund if you have that ability. But anyways, I think it's a good average bet. It's not the best.
从这个意义上说，你会发现事情要容易得多。把它搞定。就像Y Combinator是一个可靠的方法，能帮你搞定公司最早期、最脆弱的阶段，好让你进入下一个阶段，也就是寻找产品与市场的契合点（product market fit）。还有其他途径，比如你可以去找种子基金，它们能帮你起步。还有其他孵化器。我其实不太推荐其他孵化器。除了Y Combinator，我想不出你为什么要选别的。如果你有那个能力，我觉得你应该直接去找种子基金。但无论如何，我觉得这是一个不错的平均选择。它不是最好的，
You could definitely do better, but it's definitely not the worst. That's great advice. So promoted AI as a company, what is it like to work there? Are you guys hiring interns to sort of pitch us on joining promoted AI? Yeah, we need Flink experts. So if you're an expert in Flink, send me an email. That's an important hire. We also would like to hire someone for continuous integration and deployment like SRE. Those are our two biggest needs. And then we also need someone on React. If you're a React expert, we're looking for someone on that as well. So those are our open positions. But let me tell you a little bit more about working for us. We are a very lean team. We explicitly only have hired our ex-colleagues from Facebook or Google. So my co-founder, Dan, he was at Google before. Dan and I, we met at Pinterest. We were EMs there together. So that's how we met each other. And so we're only very experienced engineers. And that allows us to, and who've worked in the space before. So this allows us to build really fantastic, complicated systems in a very fast way.
你当然可以做得更好，但绝对不是最差的。这真是个好建议。那么Promoted AI作为一家公司，在那里工作是什么感觉？你们在招实习生吗？算是向我们推销一下加入Promoted AI吧？是的，我们需要Flink专家。所以如果你是Flink专家，给我发邮件。这是一笔重要的招聘。我们还想招一个负责持续集成和部署（CI/CD）的人，比如SRE。这是我们最大的两个需求。然后我们还需要一个精通React的人。如果你是React专家，我们也在寻找这样的人。所以这些是我们的空缺职位。不过让我多讲讲在我们公司工作的感受。我们是一个非常精简的团队，我们明确只招聘我们在Facebook或Google的前同事。所以我的联合创始人Dan，他以前在谷歌。Dan和我是在Pinterest认识的。我们当时都是那里的工程经理（EM）。我们就是这样认识的。所以我们只招非常有经验的工程师。这让我们能够……
Whereas we wouldn't be able to do that if we had done more of a traditional sort of company building, which is you kind of hire up like 20 people and they're maybe sort of junior or maybe unproven. And then you like build an MVP and it's like maybe pretty crappy, but it gets the job done. For the type of market we're going after, we really pitched the top of our market. And we're also trying to solve the really fantastic marketplace matching system that we're also trying to solve the really fantastic marketplace matching system that we were never really quite able to build. They have that like variety of reasons at some of these really good companies that have good brands. Like, well,
而如果我们采取更传统的公司建设方式——也就是招大约20个人，他们可能有点初级或者未经检验，然后你做一个MVP（最小可行性产品），可能挺烂的，但总算能用——我们就无法做到这一点。对于我们所追求的市场，我们直接把目标瞄准了市场最顶端。而且我们还试图解决那个非常棒的市场匹配系统，那些拥有良好品牌的优秀公司出于各种原因，在过去其实从来没有真正完全构建出来过。虽然有，但……
I'm not going to name any, but yeah. So working at promoted is like working with what if you took all of the expert engineers and just had a team of the best people and were able to move very quickly and build a really fantastic system and be able to sell it to companies where maybe they have an okay system but having it to be amazing like a really great system is really worth it for them at their scale. Wow. Yeah. I mean, I think that's a really great point you brought up about pitching experienced software engineers to come and help your team really gives an entirely different flavor than casting a wide net and saying, Hey, if you're, if you have skills, like come here, or if you are willing to learn, come here. I mean, I think both can be useful and probably
我不会点名任何公司，但在Promoted工作，就像是把你所有的专家工程师聚在一起，拥有一个由最优秀人才组成的团队，能够以极快的速度行动，构建一个真正棒极了的系统，并把它销售给这样一些公司：他们可能拥有一个还凑合的系统，但对他们目前的规模来说，拥有一个真正不可思议的、顶级的系统对他们而言确实极有价值。哇。是的，我的意思是，我觉得你提出的这一点非常棒：向经验丰富的软件 engineers（工程师）推销，让他们来帮助你的团队，这给公司带来了完全不同的格调，而不是撒大网说：“嘿，如果你有技能，就来这儿；或者如果你愿意学习，就来这儿。”我的意思是，这两者都有用，而且可能在
at different stages of growth, but I think, yeah, I hear you about, to learn, come here. I mean, I think both can be useful and probably at different stages of growth. But I think, yeah, I hear you about, you know, having been around the block a couple of times, you really sort of know the advantage of having a really cracked team going and solving. It's necessary for the stage that we're in and our strategy. There's a lot of startups out there. A ton, right? a lot of startups out there, a ton. And everyone knows the typical strategy of you throw some MVP over the wall and it needs to do something simple, but it does it. And then you get a bunch of customers and then you raise a bunch of capital and then you fix it later. You make it better and better and you go up market. We did the opposite, which is we started the top of our market, which is a much bigger
不同的成长阶段适用，但我认为，是的，我理解你的意思，关于“愿意学习，就来这儿”。我的意思是，这两者都有用，而且可能在不同的成长阶段适用。但我认为，是的，我理解你的意思，经历过几轮风雨之后，你确实能明白拥有一支真正顶尖的团队去攻坚克难的优势。这对于我们目前所处的阶段和战略来说是必要的。外面有很多初创公司。非常多，对吧？外面有很多初创公司，数不胜数。每个人都知道典型的战略：你把某个MVP扔过墙，它需要做一些简单的事情，而且它确实能做到。然后你获得了一堆客户，接着你筹集了一大笔资金，然后你以后再去修复它。你让它变得越来越好，然后向高端市场进军。我们做的是相反的事情，我们从高端市场起步，这是一个大得多的
build, and then make it work really well. And then we're going to generalize it. And eventually, we'll go raise some sort of series B or C or whatever, and we'll expand the engineering team. But we're starting from this core that is really fantastic. And you're doing more of like adding features or solutions engineering, which is more appropriate for more junior engineers who are working within an existing system, they wouldn't know how to design a really fantastic system that would work at other big companies because they've never worked at these bigger companies. So they don't know what their problems would be.
构建，然后让它运转得非常好。接下来我们要将它通用化。最终，我们会去筹集某种B轮或C轮融资，诸如此类，然后我们才会扩大工程团队。但我们是从这个真正绝佳的核心起步的。你所做的事情更偏向于添加功能或解决方案工程（solutions engineering），这更适合那些在现有系统内工作的较为初级的工程师，因为他们从未在这些大公司工作过，所以他们根本不知道如何设计一个能在其他大公司顺畅运行的真正绝佳的系统。因此他们根本不知道大公司的问题会是什么。
So how could they possibly design that sort of system? And this also allows us to work remotely. So we're all remote. This wasn't by design, it was a COVID issue, but this allows us where, because everyone has prior experience, people already know generally, this is what we're trying to build together. So there's not this big overhead of trying to explain this is why we're building it or like a lot of product management overhead or engineering management overhead. Each individual expert can self-manage to build the pieces that they already know what they're supposed to be or how they could be better because they've already seen it at other companies like say Twitter or Grab or Pinterest,
所以他们怎么可能设计出那种系统呢？这也让我们能够进行远程办公。所以我们全员远程。这不是刻意设计的，而是新冠疫情带来的结果，但这让我们得以实现：因为每个人都有过往经验，大家心里其实都大致清楚——这就是我们要一起构建的东西。所以不会有那种巨大的管理开销去解释“我们为什么要构建这个”，也没有太多的产品管理或工程管理开销。每个专家都可以自我管理，去构建他们本就知道该是什么样的、或者如何能做得更好的模块，因为他们已经在其他公司（比如Twitter、Grab或Pinterest）见过这些了，
like Facebook or Google are positive examples, but maybe also like, okay, these are overbuilt. So here are the pieces that we wouldn't really need, but here are the critical pieces that we definitely have to have that allows us to move very quickly. So that's the style of promoted where it takes some discipline. It's sometimes kind of hard. Like, oh, we're not going to do the quick, easy win. We're going to really invest in the hard stuff like streaming data systems and getting the latency down really low because we know that that's the foundation that you can build a fantastic system on
Facebook或Google是正面的例子，但可能也包括：“好吧，这些东西过度设计了，所以这些是我们其实不需要的部分，但这些是绝对不能缺少的关键部分”，这让我们能够行动得非常快。这就是Promoted的风格，它需要一定的纪律性。有时这挺难的，比如：“哦，我们不去做那些能快速轻易取胜的事，我们要真正投资于像流数据系统这样困难的东西，把延迟降得非常低”，因为我们知道这是构建一个绝佳系统的基础，
and then we'll go and expand on it later. But we build a team like that as well. Awesome. Well, thank you so much, Andrewrew i felt like this has been a great episode i mean i learned a lot it was it was great talking to you thank you i had a lot of fun as well so and thank you everyone for listening and we'll see you next time There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后再在此基础上去扩展。但我们也是围绕这种理念来组建团队的。太棒了。好的，非常感谢你，安德鲁。我觉得这是一期非常棒的节目，我学到了很多，和你聊天太棒了。谢谢你，我也玩得很开心。谢谢大家的收听，我们下次见！本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。